shake it off while I ask you this next
question
I talked to Roy Williams your head coach
at North Carolina he's in the crowd
tonight he told me during the game that
he gave you some words of encouragement
What did he say to you
he's just told me to go out there
because he told me to go out there and
be Kobe you know that's all I got to do
and you know it's a blessing that has it
you know they come out all the way y'all
here to watch me play in a regular
season game that just shows you you know
how big of a family Carolina is and any
recruit that's missing that you know
it's are they missing out what would you
say to him right now if he's listening
you might have walked out already but
still possible can you come the war days
started like that in a long time oh you
know cause no oh he's here close their
eyes close know I leave him
Luna coach Kobe has a question for you
[Applause]
her she's got a question for you nah no
question I know you got to see me get
through like I said coach I appreciate
you for coming you know I love you you
know me or let's it go past basketball
[Music]
you ty